[Music]
time now for our seen and unseen segment
where we expose what's really going on
behind the big culture stories of the
day we kick it off with a doozy what
happens when the Sports Illustrated
swimsuit edition hits the me2 era forget
swimsuits the models are wearing nothing
but buzzwords I kid you not to make some
sense of this and share this another
sweet story coming up as well
Fox News contributor Raymond Arroyo
Raymond swimsuit edition no swimsuits
but a hashtag on the models what's going
well they called it in her words and
these are empowering words on these
models supermodels here's the problem
they're saying this is empowering you're
objectifying these what you're using
them as literal billboards and I'm sorry
this is no way if you're our daughter
supposed to aspire to well this is
supposed to raise awareness of respect
for women out there I'm not gonna sexual
awareness you know sexual abuse
awareness this is an odd way to do it by
putting you know the first time in
history Sports Illustrated does a nude
spread and all women edited this edition
it was an all-female cast editing this
edition I know what they're editing I
didn't edit much here's what one here's
what the editor MJ day said of this
experience
she said it's about allowing women to
exist in the world without being
harassed or judged regardless of how
they like to present themselves well
women may read the words men are reading
the curves I can promise you and when I
saw this I thought this is a photo
spread a meet to protest that Harvey
Weinstein could have produced now it's
an outrage embarrassing yourselves
father-daughter dance canceled in New
York Staten Island public school 65 my
daughter's gone to a father-daughter
dance and in issued she goes with a
friend or grant grand surrogate
grandfather and she has a great time
well they're saying there's a Catholic
school though the the public schools
have a a code that you don't want to
violate anyone's gender identification
and by calling it a father-daughter
dance they're saying you're excluding
people but I don't quite understand this
if you're a mother who identifies as a
father go to the father-daughter dance
if your father who identifies as a
mother go to the mother to Sunday
stay at home I find this whole thing
this is not a this is a different kind
of man no not the dances omnious no one
should stay home these were beautiful
events for my wonderful son and a father
and daughter they leave lasting memories
why should it be ruined for everybody
down the street they ruin the Boy Scouts
they want to ruin the Girl Scouts I want
to ruin for turn --'tis all-male club's
all-female clubs you can't have any fun
with a particular group because
everybody has to be it then there is no
special place it's all everyone's
everything down at PS 30 they have
something called the fudge dance which
is fun fun with uncles dads wear this
fun with uncles dads grandfathers etc so
look for the etc daughter dance or the
etc Sun Dance
okay he'll be happy then what's what's
the good feel story the most uplifting
story the week Gerber baby has chosen
its spokes baby for the year it is a
little boy named Lucas Warren he's the
first child in 90 years to have Down
syndrome a special needs child chosen as
the Gerber baby
it's such a lesson and a witness
remember sixty-seven to ninety percent
of children with Down's are aborted this
is a really important lesson for the
beauty and the need for every life and
that these people are valued and loved
and should be every life has Worth and
merit and that made my night
we thank you for we needed to clean the
palate that is awesome